sorry guys this entire theory doesn't
hold water at all the massive
breakthrough success of the mcu has done
almost nothing on all caps to increase
the sales of marble comics as a matter
of fact the books are struggling big
time conversely iron man was a lesser
known marvel hero when his movie dropped
and the guardians of the galaxy were
mostly obscure comic book d-listers both
suggesting that it wasn't comic readers
that made the movies succeed it was also
the quality of the marvel movies as
movies that made people care so yeah go
ahead and try to launch a comic and or
novel and or video game while you
simultaneously meet the herculean task
of shooting and promoting an indie movie
good luck there you will need it sure
yeah absolutely i think i think if you
pull that apart a little bit there's a
couple interesting things that that that
i would respond to uh because i i want
to have empathy for that comment and
the the comments interesting and i'll
take the middle comment there uh first
about
the herculean task of trying to do it
simultaneous of a movie that's crazy you
should never try to be doing it
simultaneous to the film i would never
advocate you trying to create a comic
book while you're trying to make a movie
that's crazy you should never do that
you should you should be creating the
comic book well before you ever make the
movie for sure like you yeah you you
can't be you can't be
anybody that's ever made a movie knows
how
all-encompassing it is to make a movie
you can't do anything you can barely
feed yourself uh and pay your bills and
take your dogs on the walk while you're
trying to like you know at the same time
of making a movie like your whole life
stops just so you can do it there's no
way you're going to be able to be
managing you know the production of a
mobile game and the production of an
album and the and the production of a
comic book while you're making a movie
so
i would 100 agree with the comment about
that don't do it let's just avoid that
altogether now that doesn't mean you
shouldn't make a comic book and a movie
let's just make him at different times
right so now before you ever make the
movie let's make the comic book to then
grow the audience in a way
that that establishes pre-awareness in
the market i mean think about this think
about think about you when you make a
movie that's not based on let's just say
you find the financing let's just say
hypothetically you find magical
financing your grandma leaves you a
hundred thousand dollars in her will so
that you can make your your movie so you
make a hundred thousand dollar feature
film which is awesome right you have the
financing to do it if it's unbranded
content
when you release the movie you're
releasing it to to no fans
by definition there aren't any fans
because this has never been released in
the market before it's unbranded content
you haven't you haven't pushed it out at
all
so there isn't anyone who loves it
yet and it could be great i'm not saying
it's not great no one knows about it yet
because the movie's not out yet right so
you're releasing it into the market with
no fans just hoping and praying that
everybody shows up on opening weekend so
we can consider this a success right
so now look at look at the other the the
other path is we know that that it's
it's uh that any movie one when you
start production it's gonna be two years
before that movie ever sees a lot of day
but even even if you go through the the
normal you know pre-production principle
photography post-production distribution
process but let's say even before you
get to that
to to to the production standpoint
leading up to it
right you go ahead and establish the
market say with a comic book or podcast
let's just say podcast right so you say
you launch the podcast ideally maybe
podcast and comic book right but let's
just stick with one let's say let's say
podcast if you have 10 000 people
who love your podcast
that is connected
narratively to the movie that you will
you will be releasing in the future
right so you you you open the brand up
to 10 000 people
who love the narrative universe the
story the characters the concept like
they're in it right and then and now
they're your fans they're in your brand
they're supportive because we love this
podcast it's awesome we're fans of this
whole thing
when you make your movie and release
your movie guess what you're doing
you're going to release the movie and
there's 10 000 fans that already love it
they already love it
they may not love the movie yet but they
love the brand
and releasing a movie to 10 000 fans who
already love it is better than releasing
a movie to no fans
that
to no fans right like that like that
that's the punch line is it's of course
like think about this if if i if i if i
release if i release a podcast
and i and i
create 10 000 fans
and then i release a novel
i release that novel
into a market that's warm it's a warm
market not a cold market now i've warmed
the market with 10 000 fans now there's
10 000 fans that can buy my book
and then let's say i get 20 bucks per
book do the math 10 000 times 20. that
equals out to a profit potential as
opposed to
not doing anything first and then just
releasing my novel into the market to
zero fans
does that does that
mean that there's no way for me to make
money of course not the people that do
that make money in books all the time
but it's a harder road to release to no
fans
than it is to release to 10 000 fans
it's reductive thinking you almost have
to make yourself a little bit dumber to
use common sense for that to make sense
i feel like we're overthinking it like
of course it's better to have ten
thousand fans already
loving your stuff when you release your
movie of course of course
right i mean it just it just it just
makes sense it and so so whatever way
you can establish the community of fans
any community of fans that love your
brand and love your ip ahead of the
release of the movie
then
when you release that movie you're gonna
increase your chances for success does
it guarantee success of course not
but you have a higher chance of success
than if you release that same movie into
a cold market
that's the punchline now then if you add
in the fact that
there's probably not you're you've
minimized your chance of gaining
investment
from a private equity investor or studio
because it's unbranded content right
like that that's a whole other
conversation that that just to get the
financing you need to have that market
presence by and large that comes by way
of attachment or by by brand awareness
uh of the ip right but but so so there's
lots of reasons you need to do this but
i completely agree you shouldn't do at
the same time it'll make you go crazy
right that's that you know it'll make
your marriage fall apart and make you
grow a crazy beard and make you stressed
out like
it's just it's bad news like you
shouldn't you should not try to juggle
all the like the filmmaking is so crazy
and difficult we all know being on set
it's just too difficult to do all those
things at the same time right
spread them out
warm the market
then release the movie so that's the
middle comment the second thing i'll
address about the comment uh really is
the first part of the comment where the
the commenter said uh that the the mcu
didn't boost sales of marvel comics and
and and i would agree with that as well
i would i would absolutely i'm agreeing
with the commenter more than i'm
disagreeing with commenter the commenter
because there's a narrative reason for
that is is when they when kevin feige
launched the mcu it was a different
canon
than the comics
and so you know canon is sort of the
official narrative that goes along with
a franchise or an ip and so what is the
official story
and there were i mean there was what 70
years or of of of marvel comic narrative
that had been going on forever and and
when they started the mcu
they wanted to
start a new canon because that was way
too much complexity way too much baggage
uh way too much story to deal with
adequately it just confines the
filmmakers too much right because
because there's you know
the only way you can make this movie is
you if you go read 3 000 comic books uh
that doesn't become an attractive uh
entry point for filmmaker to want to do
right so uh so it's just too much
baggage and so they they they said the
mcu will be a special cannon it's going
to be a new canon that the comic books
will still be the thing will be a thing
and they'll still have their own canon
they'll have their own stories that will
continue but we're going to set up a new
completely fresh consistent canon that
starts with the mcu that won't just be
the movies they actually have a line of
comic books that that is a special
mcu line of comic books that's tied in
with the mcu that goes along with the
mcu but those comic books aren't part of
the
the legacy marvel comic books that that
you know that uh that are out there and
so yeah of course when when when when
the iron man movies and the avengers
movies and all these movies came out
they didn't boost sales of the comic
books
because the comic books didn't extend
the story of the movies and so from a
transmedia perspective the incentive for
the audience to migrate to a different
platform is that the the story in the
different platform is going to give them
more insight and more narrative and more
payoff
of this the thing that they love and so
if they were to learn more about this
these movies and the tv shows and things
like that by going to the comic books
maybe they would have
but because
all marvel fans knew that with new
marvel fans or even legacy fans that
there was a disconnected canon there was
no incentive for them to go uh check out
the uh you know check out the comic
books and uh and and i don't think kevin
feige
at marvel necessarily intended for these
things to to
uh for the the comic book sales to spike
so
that's why they didn't spike they broke
the canon and there was never a business
objective or a creative objective of
kevin feige who's over the puppet master
of the mcu and so uh so so so of course
of course those didn't spike now does
that mean see this is we don't want to
we don't want to conflate that to say
well that means comic books connected
with
with with movies don't work and there's
no reason because they no it
they can make it work like if the canon
would be consistent
with uh with the the film and television
and and they work together now all then
all of a sudden they begin to feed each
other you look at the the difference in
how marvel treated the legacy uh you
know the the legacy comics um uh
with marvel and and compare that to how
lucasfilm deals with the comic books um
in star wars it's very different and so
all of a sudden you know you watch the
sequel trilogy and you have kylo ren who
is who is uh the head of the knights of
ren and uh and uh
in the movies the knights of ren
aren't really explained like who they
are and how how he got roped in with
those with that crew seemed just like
you know it's a kid that kind of got
involved with some
bad friends that took him in a bad
direction they sort of allude to it so
you can still enjoy the movie without
all that backstory knowledge right but
they revealed who the knights of ren are
what happened to to ben solo after he
left luke skywalker's uh you know jedi
academy and kind of went off on his own
uh and and uh
they tell that complete story
in comic books and so now the comic
books is is now extending
the film uh franchise the trilogy and
now there's synergy between the two
things and so now obviously we have film
fans who are migrating over to the comic
book does everybody migrate of course
not everybody migrates right but you get
your the the comic books do absolutely
benefit
from the migration of a certain
percentage of the film fans that want to
dig deeper and know more or there are
some people that haven't seen the movies
that are into the comic books then find
the entry point in the comic books and
then find their way over to the movies
because they are now interested in the
knights of ren and that's part of the
movies and so it can flow both ways
right so so you absolutely see spikes in
sales when there's intentional narrative
synergy what i call additive
comprehension between the works right
but that's an intention that needs to be
made from a business perspective a
business model perspective and also a
narrative intention that goes along with
that you've got to tie these stories
together in a very intentional way to
have that happen if you don't intend it
from a business perspective and you
don't intentionally tie these stories
together narratively of course you'll
never see a spike but that doesn't that
doesn't
lead you to a conclusion of you should
never have a comic book right like like
that that's it's a complete like it
depends on how you execute the comic
book and how you and how you execute it
in the context where it goes along with
the film it's the contextual information
that you kind of need to be able to make
that work right so uh so so absolutely
uh uh
the the
the commenter is right in the analysis
but i think the conclusion that's
inferred from that analysis is is
incorrect you just don't want to
conflate it and apply it to oh you never
need to do a comic book comic books are
dumb like you don't need to get to that
conclusion let's just do it in the right
way if you intend it if you intend to
spike that means you have to do it the
right way that's all that means they
didn't
star wars actually did this with with
what they called the extended universe
which they when when lucasfilm or when
lucasfilm was sold to disney uh they had
been writing novels and comic books and
and especially novels for 20 years uh
and there were hundreds of novels and
video games and comic books all the
stuff that disney inherited by way of
the purchase not just the original film
trilogy of the prequel trilogy there
were there were hundreds and hundreds of
of of
licensed works that were created and it
was too much
for
lucas or for disney to
figure out so they de-canonized all that
stuff
and said this isn't an official story
anymore
from from at this point on we're
creating new canon we're disconnecting
from this other stuff right so so
so in the same way the new stuff that
they've released doesn't spike
the sales of all that extended universe
stuff that that that's older because
there's a narrative disconnect right and
it's not their business intention so of
course whenever you have that disconnect
it's not gonna it's not gonna
achieve that result and i don't think
they're disappointed in it because they
never intended to do that in the first
place and the last part of the comment
is like uh you know talked about luck
with any luck this would have of course
you listen nothing's ever guaranteed
everything like you know whether it's
luck or kismet or or you know fate or
destiny whatever it is like of course
there's always going to be an element of
of
right place right time uh uh what do you
call it luck we call it just whatever
you call it karma i don't know there's
there's something that that this x
factor that has to happen for things to
be to pop off to be successful know if
anybody ever tells you that there's a
guaranteed
way or a guaranteed model of success in
the film industry or the creative
industry or creative content
production that there's a guaranteed
methodology
of like the silver bullet do this every
time and it's gonna pop and and be
amazing and be huge if anybody ever says
that you need to you need to you know
run the opposite direction because it's
not true
it it all you can have the best laid
plans you can have the best stories the
best ideas the best business model and
and sometimes it just doesn't work for
a thousand different reasons
and it's not because
your business model is bad and it's not
because
your idea was bad or you're like just
sometimes it doesn't work and it's weird
and and it's just like and or sometimes
culturally
something it happens in it and something
pops off in a just right place right
time the right idea and who knew that
baby yoda would blow up the way baby
yoda did like you know like it was that
luck was that right place right time
what like what was it i don't know and
so so yeah like
this anything that i say is is not
silver bullet i think you know
anybody that writes a screenwriting book
of like this is the way to structure a
screenplay that's not a guaran if you
use the structures to guarantee that
your screenplay is going to sell or be
good
of course not of course you need some
element of quote unquote luck
in addition to
best laid plans and
and and and you know and approaches that
increase your chances right that's all
i'm saying is if you if you use a
multi-platform approach to attack the
market in as many ways possible to use
all the tools and toolbox generate
audience uh have a market presence for
your ip uh be able to to to create an
ecosystem that feeds itself in a
commoditized market before you get to
the big st the big film and television
investment heavy things that are so
risky for people and they don't want to
lose their jobs because they don't want
to take the risk if you just do that
stuff it doesn't guarantee you selling
anything it doesn't guarantee you
succeeding in anything it increases your
chances
you know from from a from a sp with a
sports analogy
if if if
if you just take an unbranded piece of
content and and you just release it into
the market and you try to sell the
script you try to you know uh you just
you just you just put it out there right
it's like
it's like with the football analogy it's
like being back on your own one yard
line throwing a hail mary all the way
down the field
right
that's hard
like it's rare that that works it's very
difficult
right and and uh does does every now and
then
does does it work for somebody of course
and that's the trap you see somebody on
the other you know a few feet down from
you say oh they completed their pass
that means i can complete my pass which
is true technically it's true but you
may spend 20 years trying to throw that
same hail mary down the field and never
and it just doesn't work and that's not
your fault and it's just not doesn't
mean you're a bad person or a bad
creative it just didn't work so what i
say is
let's run a few plays to move down the
field a little bit let's do the five
yard podcast let's do the 15 yard comic
book let's do the seven yard
uh board game right and let's get to the
point to where we're at the 50-yard line
and throw the hail mary because
everything in the film industry is going
to be a hail mary everything even the
studios with the stuff that they do is
going to be hail mary's nothing's
guaranteed right but every especially
for independent filmmakers everything
that we make is going to be hail mary
so but i would rather throw the hell
mary from the 50 than my own one
that's all i'm saying it increases your
odds increases your chances but you do
have that have to have that little piece
of magic you have to have that little
piece of magic or luck or whatever you
call it in order for these things to
work and that's
that's the cool thing about the industry
right you just there's
it's not ones and zeros like the matrix
there's there's something else that that
that comes in
to
all the stuff that you make and you know
and and uh you know it makes something
come alive and that's cool and then
that's interesting and that makes what
makes it exciting so so i agree
with almost every single thing in that
comment which is which is but
maybe i have a different perspective or
a different angle in it and sorry for
those of us who don't know football what
is the definition of that type of past
oh okay yeah
sorry i forget no that's okay yeah so uh
so hail mary is is uh uh just you know
it's usually your last resort you're way
far back on the other end of the field
and and you just like throw it way up in
the air and just hope that somebody
catches it right it's not really a you
know a well-designed tactical play it's
it's the hail mary let's just hope and
pray that something happens and it works
right like that's that's uh that's the
hail mary and it usually only happens
when teams are getting ready to lose and
they're running out of time and there's
nothing else to do except throw really
far down the field really high in the
air and just see what happens